[Music]
oh
hello we're here with tim dillon because
i need to get my youtube numbers up
hey tim anything i can do
anything i can do thank you for having
me you are such a bad match for the good
for you audience it's
this is truly just to get more youtube
subscribers yeah i mean and
it saddens me that more of them haven't
taken a liking to me
so ladies out there with your candles
come on over to the tim dillon show why
are you wearing sunglasses i'm a venture
capitalist right now
i've moved into that i i appreciate
comics and comedy but i'm now
realizing that my strongest um
attribute has always been i'm a keen i
have a keen eye
for the market i'm investing and
i'm building businesses so if you want
to build businesses we can build
businesses
but i'm just bored with uh you know
entertainment
i'm just i'm in a different sphere okay
i put myself in a different space
after you just bought stock in uh movie
theaters amc movie theaters i went in
i went in heavy and hold the line and uh
we are showing that the institutional
wall street and the big money players
that we are resting back wrestling back
a little power back what explain this
give me some context i know yeah um it
was hurting my views
on on reddit there's something called
wall street bets on reddit
and it is a uh you know it's a reddit
where people discuss stock prices
okay uh everybody on that reddit they
were talking about you know go
they went into gamestop because all
these big hedge funds
short stocks like like game stuff can i
be an idiot
can you explain to me what i had i've
tried to date men that are hedge fund
managers i know that's something
it's just a lot of rich people to pull
their money together that's the person
you want to marry but what
is a hedge fund it's a lot of high net
worth individuals it's an investment
vehicle for high net worth individuals
that pull their money together and then
somebody obviously manages that money
and invests and invested
in exactly not like my 401k no
no i mean everyone could have 401k so
you could work at a place and have a
401k a week later i just still don't
know what a hedge fund is you just
explained it and i'm more confused well
it's just well it's just it's a it's a
fund for very wealthy people that
want to make a lot of money okay and a
lot and they
you know a lot of these hedge funds
shorted stocks like gamestop
because games started stocks what does
that mean betting it will fail
betting that it's not going to be
valuable because no one's going to go
into
all of that because of the amazon amc
movie theater killed the business all of
these things right
okay so what people at wall street bet
started to do is said hey
wouldn't it be fun if we started buying
these stocks
so that the people that shorted them had
to then cover their bets because if
you're betting on a stock to fail
and it doesn't fail you got to cover the
cover the short right
so it's actually they force gamestop up
my producer ben knows how much
i went from like four dollars to i think
it peaked around like 490.
right so from four dollars to 490
dollars a share i know it's like 220. so
now
oh this is like it's like a prank it's a
prank it's also like basically it's
saying you guys have manipulated the
market for a very long time
you've artificially inflated the the
price of things you have
you know played this game now we have
the information
people on reddit have the information we
have a catch uh things like robin hood
and these apps that allow you to trade
stocks
why not why not get into the game why
can't regular people get into the game
in the same way that all these
institutional wall street guys have been
in the game forever
right and then of course as soon as that
started happening the government
pressured robin hood the
app everyone was trading on and then i'm
sure they had other pressure coming from
other
people um and they stopped trading today
uh on those stocks right on gamestop on
amc
yeah robin hood you couldn't do gme amc
or nokia
right so the three companies that people
were pushing they said you cannot trade
on those companies which is insane
insane seemingly illegal
because nobody was doing anything wrong
crap nobody was doing anything illegal
the sec is not investigating any of
those companies there's no reason to
really freeze trading
so robinhood has now come out and said
we're gonna open limited trading
tomorrow and watch it which still seems
sus but you know so again it's like this
is what happens when you try to get a
seat at the big boy table
uh and this is kind of a movement that
started on reddit
that is now becoming somewhat somewhat
powerful and distressing and it's
costing a lot of these hedge fund guys
money
so i got in for you know a decent amount
of money it just feels like chaos like i
just it's
chaos like i feel like we're listening
it's it's chaos
like we hacked they hacked the stock
market yeah it's chaos
and they are they want to see to the
table and they know that they're not
going to get a seat at the table like
this
but they also know that this can leave
some egg on the faces
of very wealthy people and why not
that's the real question why not even
ben shapiro who defends the markets and
capitalism and everything
came out and said um you'd have to have
a heart of stone not to laugh
at what's happening yeah like most
people are sitting back and going
now of course there's the argument
against it saying that it completely
turns the stock market into casino and
blah blah blah yeah
however was it ever not a casino it was
always a
people in this country especially after
this quarantine after being told they
can't work being told they had to
shutter their businesses
not getting any support from the
government are like and then watching
the stock market just
keep going up not reflecting any of the
reality on the ground
the stock market keeps going up keeps
going up all these people are without
jobs
why not rich people getting richer why
would they not do this and i'm happy to
be a part of it like why
would this have happened without the
pandemic
i don't think so it might have
it certainly could have like because i
do i do feel like
we've you know all gone into a
feral state of self-preservation every
man for himself
right like i feel like we've just well
you have people on reddit that are
showing you how much they made
and going i can treat i can help my
mother who has lyme disease
now like now i can help
somebody that didn't have the money now
i can write my mother a check
pay for my sister is this what the
redistribution of power and wealth looks
like
is it happening i mean i i well it was
until they shut it down
who's they the guy like robin hood
the ceo of robin hood decided to and by
who influenced that person it guarantees
people from the binding administration
and big money players on wall street
that's
wildly are we russia that's wildly
corrupt right it's we're living in a
mafia criminal state i've been
quite open about this i mean it's these
are the oligarchs yes
this is an oligarchy oligarchs are
you know people that control vast
industries there's
a handful of them and they have a
tremendous amount of power
and those are the people that are
pressuring the ceo of robin hood himself
a billionaire
these are his friends these are the
people he sees at the parties
these are the guys he hangs out with in
the hamptons in palm beach these are the
people who
his kids are going to go to school with
their kids and they're picking up the
phone going hey man
what's going on people forget that i
mean like
the only thing i really know about in
terms of like making laws and stuff in
government is like animal abuse stuff
and when you go in there and try to pass
an animal bill and you're like oh we got
it this is abuse someone's like well
that's my friend's
head's an elephant and i don't want to
he's yeah it's all just
a lot of that yeah so that's what people
are saying my friend has an elephant
fund
that's getting really screwed because a
bunch of
your people are fucking with us so
please stop that now tomorrow we're all
waiting
we're holding the line it's called hold
up i don't know when this comes out what
is this
yeah what is the whole thought i mean i
know the schedule is podcast like
she records it releases it in four and a
half months um
but again that's why we try to add some
production value to our podcast i'm
sorry all right
that's something that's why people
that's that's why people like podcasts
i'm sorry it doesn't look like a high
school theater production
whenever somebody recommends a podcast
they go what you got to listen to this
the production value
is amazing it's do you see the lighting
yeah you and ox jones could use a little
more lighting to be honest well pay for
it
let's see what happens i i think it'll
be very interesting to see what happens
tomorrow morning when when the market
opens this amc
fly and we're hoping it does we hope
gamestop flies and then you're gonna
sell
and then you're gonna sell no we're
gonna hold i think the game here is to
buy and hold and force their feed to the
fire yeah
i may sell no i'm kidding this is good
i'm not gonna sell i'm gonna hold
i will everyone should hold that's what
it's about
for like four we've i've known you for
about a year now this is the happiest
i've ever seen you
well it's exciting i mean this is
nothing's exciting anymore
because everything even though we've
watched all the porn even though the
news is so horrible it's boring it's
like you turn the news like everyone's
dead and dying well we're so
desensitized yeah
it's it's so dis so this is something
that's actually happening where you're
like oh let me
i can get involved i can check my thing
you know what i mean it's like an
older a boomer video game no this is for
young people
this is for young people that are sick
of a system
that doesn't really have they don't have
any
any power they don't have a stake they
don't have a seat at the table will
anything permanently change after this
feel like i have skin in the game
not for the good i think probably
they'll limit people's ability to trade
they'll limit all these things they'll
say you gotta have a certain amount of
money to trade they will
try to enforce compliance in any way
they can are they able to do it i don't
know guys they
portnoy have been out there saying this
is
um you know hold the line don't sell
force these guys feet to the fire
because what they're doing is
illegal you can't shut down trading of
publicly traded stock if it's not being
investigated
they're doing that to protect the
interest of big money players
it's wrong yeah and guys like portnoy to
his credit have come out and said that
and when i leave here we're interviewing
the head of wall street bets the guy who
runs the reddit uh where all this stuff
started happening
but this is a good i think it's a good i
think anyone defending this
uh defending the wall street side of it
publicly
has been to jeffrey epstein's island and
there's photos of it and they got it
they got an envelope this morning with a
photo of them and justly maxwell and
then they started to go
well the market must function in a way
that we you know but i mean why not why
not let the little guy go out and make a
little money
and force these you know whales to cough
up some money
there's nothing wrong with that and i
know people are gonna go well it just
turns the market into a casino and like
you don't really believe that amc is
valuable and you don't
really believe that this is gamestop
valuable and it's like hey
number one do you want to start really
digging deep
on all the money that's been made in the
market
and can we really assess how serious
people were about
what they believed and didn't believe at
the time they made trades so at the end
of the day it's like this is
legal it's above board and i'm i'm i'm
for it that's why i'm
i consider myself now a venture
capitalist
and i will continue to raise capital and
allocate it in the way that i see fit
tim we've been through a lot together in
the scoring yes it's been wild uh we
trauma bonded in the beginning
yes uh uh and i do want us to address
the fact that we got a fight the other
day we did because i cancelled the
podcast we got in a real fight
i canceled the podcast like like i mean
so go look at elise
yes to do a walkthrough he was due to
come to the podcast on sunday
yes uh his call time was 10 at 10 15 he
texted me and said i can't make it i
have 10 people waiting here
i didn't realize that see that's what i
didn't realize and that's what i
apologize five people
and to the staff um i had no idea that
the
the podcast was the filming of a movie
like
i thought it was just a producer and you
do you think i know how to work any of
this equipment yeah you think what is
this
yeah i don't i just i'm not rick
glassman what do you think this is
i just this is the real production i
know but why
why no you don't need all these people
and i don't want to take any of their
jobs away because they all they're all
working very hard they're all on their
phone and everything and i know how how
how hard they all work and how essential
they are called fake business yeah
it's exactly what it is called uh but i
didn't realize that
how did i realize that i would have
rescheduled but that walked was like the
only time like we got the tenants out
you can do the walk through
but what happened because we had a we
are so on the same page
all the time we had like a real fight
like we both went
into our inner child i think well i i
said i think the only thing i said that
was even
slightly uh was i said it's not uh two
broke girls it's a podcast and you're
like very
angry at that it was a very it was such
a light touch of a thing
and you got vicious you got very angry i
i lost my temper it doesn't happen a lot
and i was just it was a it was a
fun little thing to say it was no but it
wasn't like
because it's so it fascinates me when uh
comedians because we're so rough with
each other
right when you go too far like when
someone i don't know
there's always going to be this unspoken
thing
between old hollywood and young
hollywood and that's that's what's
happening here
and i'm old hollywood yeah it's legit
you're a legend by the way you're not
any hollywood
i'm your young internet you've never
been hollywood but that is hollywood no
it's young internet no but that's no
hollywood still exists
no no one cares about your friends like
sandra bullock no one cares about them
i'm just saying no one cares
the fucking that's the time the thing
where she wore the blindfold in the
canoe got 50
million views four years ago i'm just
saying bird box
bringing up bird box the horror movie on
netflix i mean this is what you're
here's the difference here's what here's
what about perfect strangers that was
fun too
you guys i'm 17 years old
i'm a 17 year old tick tocker i
i i why do you want to be the future
kevin spacey
stop hanging out with these young people
tim i am trying to protect you listen
i understand you want this to be a
sunset boulevard where you're at the top
of the stairwell
and you're like with one look i'll do a
multicam
i understand that we will have taylor
tomlinson getting in fun
little skirmishes with people at a
restaurant the reason
there will be laughter we pump in the
people watching these shows brains have
been
broken um the reason the reason i need
you to come early is because we shoot
this on film
yeah well it's beautiful and i don't i
respect that we all
know that you put a lot into everything
you do and i respect you i try too hard
with the podcast now
you put a lot into it and that's so much
hey that's okay i overthink it
yeah maybe i don't know i don't even
know if i'm good at podcasting that's
the other thing
but i think you are but it's a very
different thing like you have
celebrities on and you prepare
and you do all this stuff and i respect
that but it's like what we do it's just
that i mean
tim i i don't i don't have the white man
thing of i'm just like who wouldn't want
to hear me talk for three hours about
anything like i don't i'm not allowed to
be boring i have to be twice as good
to get half as much respect um okay
you disagree uh maybe well how so
i don't know you have to be twice as
good i mean i just get half as much i
mean
got you guys is that a line from like a
country song
you guys can definitely work in nine to
five
nobody listening cause i'm a woman
is that true i'm just saying think about
i was thinking about this the other day
cause i was like how long am i going to
do this podcast
is there any proof in history that
people want to listen to women talk well
three hours a week always their fault
is it always the people's fault has
there ever been a famous female radio
host
terry gross like who's the who i mean
i'm trying
i'm trying to think women aren't famous
like like for
uh uh there are soothing voices what
about half the country that are women
that are not listening to those women
that's great agree agree i mean i i
i like women i listen to i'm just saying
in the history of our entertainment
yes what who has been the female radio
host
like because you talk about um you know
howard stern and whose footsteps you're
following they're big dj
people like angie martinez on hot 97
downtown julie brown
yeah they're kennedy yeah they're people
but but
we're digging yeah but who i i'm trying
to assign blame for that i can't
assign blame i've just you're you're
saying it whether we we then
now that we've established that we have
to assign blame yeah and we have to go
well what
well who is it toxic masculinity let's
blame that is it that it works well but
then there's half the country's women
no i no agree i was joking but
like when people like put out more like
do three shows a week like joe does i'm
like i feel like i'm good in small doses
right but that's your own internal thing
it might be my insecurity it's your
internal thing i mean
if i had guests my show would be
destroyed
how because by them i don't have an
interest in talking to hillary duff
i'm sure she's a lovely person i don't
know why she doesn't have an interest in
talking to you
great and we're good we're good see this
is the thing with you you're like
hollywood doesn't care and i'm like we
don't care me and my friends don't care
it's just a reality we don't care none
of us
want to walk into a writer's room yeah
with people that couldn't make it as
stand-ups
and hear that our jokes aren't uh funny
enough or they're they're not they're
they need to be more sensitive or more
whatever yeah
and then go to a network and have a
network tell us this and then have it's
got to go through sales and advertising
and lawyers and legal
we don't need any of that i mean that'll
go we really don't need any of that it's
so true i mean i think the thing that we
like of the hollywood is dead argument
i'm the first one to sort of make that
argument
i mean i guess i'm just like naive to a
fault in that i
still like
broadway and want to make a film like i
still have that
hollywood i would never say like
hollywood's like i still have a love of
the art
if you're a comedian yeah
going online and building a fan base yes
it makes a hell of a lot more sense than
playing this game here
as a comedian if you're 19 with a
six-pack and you're hot
yeah get on cobra kai yeah get on one of
those shows yeah i'm
36. i don't care anymore i don't want to
talk to these showrunners i don't want
to talk to people that i wrote on the
roads to snoop
i don't care it doesn't matter to me so
it's like
you know and and good i feel attacked no
no it's not you but it's like at the end
of the day it's like no what is
tired tv shows are like it is you take a
really talented funny person with a lot
of heat
you put them in a room with a bunch of
people that are way less talented
than they are right uh dilute their
vision sanitize them and it's it's never
as good but so
is there never going to be another
seinfeld there's never going to be
another
not from
there are sitcoms that don't exist
anymore no one wants to watch them
yeah no one cares curb is great show
right
i mean the ranch is huge on netflix but
okay
but for who i'm just they're the numbers
are white
it's the ranch do you know the types of
the same people that listen to your
podcast oh they don't
it's a very right the people that watch
the ranch
are mongoloids they're absolute
orbs of flesh they get home from
whataburger
they have blue hands and toes from
circulation problems
that collapse on a couch and they just
watched around
good there should be something for them
i'm not trying to steal that audience
i'm not trying to steal the audience of
the practical jokers where
10 years later they still think it's a
prank oh
look at they really got each other no
they didn't dummy
like i don't want those people can go be
those people yeah god bless them i love
the jokers but
you know i don't want a fan base of
brain dead
uh like you know zombies and i think for
me you're making me realize how
insecure i am because it's like podcasts
it's like there's nothing to protect you
you know like if you're on a show you
can be like you know
it's a little bit like you can blame
like as well you can blame other people
podcast you take
all the blame yeah and i just am so
afraid
of the internet because they turn on
people so fast
sure you know what i'm saying like
sometimes people's fan bases turn
on them you know well there's nothing
you could do about that people could say
whatever they want about you and people
uh you know can turn on you or can can
like you
and it's you know but at the end of the
day is it sustainable networks it's all
sustainable
are networks sustainable do you think
they can't turn on you you think netflix
can turn on you
you think you know how many how many
instances have we seen well no hollywood
is very forgiving
hollywood is forgiving to a fault you
can fail for
so many times in hollywood and they will
keep writing youtube like you worked
your ass off but you also
were like a chosen person you got chosen
now you worked for it
but you got to realize you were a
handful of people that
were chosen it's like that's kind of
what it is now you worked your ass off
for it
but at the end of the day it's like if
you're not chosen
i went out with a pilot it didn't work i
went out had adam mccabe produced he
didn't have me
didn't work maybe that's the case how
many times am i supposed to go through
that
15 20 30. or am i and live on the street
while i do that like why why would i do
that when i have all the means
to entertain people of mine you don't
want to act or
you just don't want to do it we all do
but it's not possible it's not possible
because
at the end of the day everyone i have
called about to set up a show with you
wants to do it and
movie i understand that but that's the
and i'm putting yourself on the foot and
i appreciate it no if they want to do it
let's let's do it
and then we'll get to the end where they
go we we we thank you and we really
appreciate this we're not putting it on
the air like
we're cutting you out of the entire
we're reaching out to we're recasting
well i'm glad i spent 16 months doing
this
that's the problem i don't want to
devote let me ask you a question which
is like
now joe rogan was the one who kind of
gave me this advice now i know you're
saying oh he's not that successful and
that's
i get it he cares about him he's not
famous he has no money but here's what
we got
about joe rogan joe rogan was famous
from network television first
sure joe rogan is like he's famous for
how many people
you got he had a mma how's the rest of
the cast in news radio doing
i'm just saying joe was famous before he
started podcasting your honor i rest
the state rest can we stop pretending
that joe was like an open micro when he
started his podcast
he was a household name when he started
his podcast i think his podcast was what
made him
the name he is now though yes of course
but he was
famous when he started would it have
made more sense for him to just
try to get sitcoms on the air every year
no back then it was different but here's
my question for you yes as someone who
is like super naive and probably dumb
and i banged my head against the wall i
stayed with you
that is none of that is true i stay in
relationships longer than i should i'm
dumb i'm naive tell me i'm wrong but
hollywood is course correcting they just
want to do what makes them money they're
a dumb business they're dumb
they're not smart people right you know
they're not making
uh uh black panther two because they
want to help equality in black lives
matter
because they made money right so as soon
as they see what makes money they will
pivot and start changing
but totally agree you guys are just so
pissed off at hollywood that you're just
like burning all fucking down cause i'm
pissed because you hurt my feelings five
years ago i'm not pissed off but i'm
also like
what's the show that i really see on tv
that i
want to be a part of and i don't see any
interesting
i don't see any shows where i go man
like the shows i like
like succession and things like that
that i love right amazing that are great
shows
but then i'm like okay where are the com
who's blowing up from
from tv shows right yeah who's getting a
real fan base
as a comedian from a tv show at the
moment i don't see anybody yeah
i see a lot of people making a living
online i see a lot of people getting
fans online i don't see anybody
right now making i i know people with tv
shows that are broke
and i know them and they they can't sell
tickets yeah it doesn't pay
the way it used to it does it doesn't
mean it's what it used to be well for a
stand-up comedian if you're not playing
yourself you're not
uh going to be able to move tickets you
know like billy gardel played a
character
right in that mike and molly show he
should have played billy garden you'd
have to play tim tam
yeah and listen i think maybe in a few
years i'm not against that i save some
money
we we make another run at development
but like at the moment
i don't see the reason for it that's why
i'm getting out of la because
i'm doing awesome tell me about it how
did this you did made this decision
without me
well i made it in a 24-hour span of time
because i called some very smart people
and a lot of them are out and a lot of
them are going and they're all
primarily internet people and they're
all going we don't need to be here
the response to elon musk leaving the
state can't be fuck elon musk which is
what
is going to uh correct okay uh
gavin newsom and the government here is
basically like yeah fuck him
so if you're gonna say fuck him you're
gonna say fuck me you're gonna say fuck
everybody
and the problem with that is it costs an
exorbitant amount of money to live here
the climate for entrepreneurs is
horrible the climate for people to live
is getting worse every year and you're
spending a lot of money and
traditional hollywood is not the bread
and butter of anyone i know
anymore i think we can all agree
that my mental health is peaking
tip top shape peeking i think we can all
say that i won mental health the pica
which mountain
i think we can all agree that no one's
mental health
is more healthy than mine i agree with
that you wrote a book about it
did you use better help i did not you
know better help
when we read these ads i get so annoyed
because i just get frustrated that i
didn't have this when i was a teenager
can you just rewrite your book as a
better help ad
i mean honestly i love better help you
guys should subscribe to it but i worry
that my book becomes obsolete if you
guys start using better help yeah
this is how much i believe in better
help i'm losing money
on my book sales driving you to better
help
which is difficult as a licensed
professional
um better hub is great because it
matches you with your own licensed
professional therapist
you can start communicating under 48
hours and
here's a fun fact you can do whatever
you want because it's online yeah so you
can do it like
drive-through of a jack-in-the-box hold
up the line get some help
get therapy while driving through jack
of the box yeah great tacos go for it
that's i i think if somebody is uh uh
getting
therapy from better help while driving
through jack in the box they're good
they don't need a therapist
they know they have strong boundaries
they know what they need they know who
they are they know their purpose maybe
they just want to chat
it's not self-help it's uh you know
it's a wild time to drive down to a
therapist i don't want to go to a
therapist right now and like get covid
in the waiting room
yeah i want to talk to robot therapists
on the computer real people
that are talking to me through the
computer and the best thing about it is
they offer it's well it's not only do
they offer but it is
literally more affordable than
traditional counseling did you know that
yeah well traditional therapy is
it's so exorbitant it's like criminal
yeah but this is what it should cost
what i'm saying and and the response
time 48 hours therapists have the
response in 48 hours have the gall think
about this therapists have the gall to
charge someone who is suffering
i am suffering i have anxiety disorders
i am depression
great come see me i'm going to charge
you 300
for 45 minutes like you're making me
sicker
with your practice yeah we can charge
sick people anything yeah
you ever been to movie theater criminal
i'm already sad i want to watch this
movie
visit betterhelp.com whitney that's
better h-e-l-p
and join the over 1 million people
taking charge of their mental health
with the help of an experienced
professional
in fact so many people have been using
better health that they are recruiting
additional counselors in all 50 states
i'm available
special offer for good for you listeners
get 10 off your first month at
betterhelp.com
whitney love it you know
i feel like i've been clear about this
my first stand-up special i talked about
balls
i had my second stand-up special i
talked about i've been talking about
balls for 15 years
so you also have built a career on balls
much like manscape
but i have i have uh uh been asking and
manscape listened
we got it you guys got to pull together
the balls are a mess
you want us to put our heads down there
our tongue's down there but you're not
making it very welcoming
help us help you you're not a cat your
tongue's not that rough you gotta
manscape yourself
you got to manscape yourself
you trim trim trim clean up
shave deodorize moisturize but also
yes but only with manscapes exactly they
offer all those things no
i've seen uh guys try to do it on their
own with the hotel razor looks like
herpes
they don't know how to shave against the
grain with the grain whatever it is i
don't know what i'm looking at here
like you have to sh there's a certain
way to shave
yeah and it is not with the hotel razor
that's for sure yeah those those
the pubes down there are coarse if you
go to wash away
you take your little towel your little
white towel go to wash away all your
little pube
splinters and it's covered in blood the
day
comes wrong the days are over uh
your glory days are over guys your balls
are no longer allowed to smell like
scallops
they're no longer allowed to smell like
ceviche they're no longer allowed to
have weird red bumps like those days are
over women have options now we have
dating apps
we can do like we're not in we're no
longer living in villages where there's
two options for suitors
okay we have other options now get
your dick in order and you make those
balls lickable
suckable what i'm saying
yep so the performance package comes
with the new and improved lawnmower 3.0
the weed whacker the ear and nose hair
trimmer
performance boxers brief and a travel
bag all of which very nice this is also
just an excellent gift uh the guy that
i'm dating
has started pilfering uh my manscaped
stuff that we keep
here because they sponsor us he starts
like stealing it
guys love it oh he's a thief he's a
thief yes great
not a red flag
what are you holding up there you know
what else here it's a great all wipes
it's a great gift great gift try one out
okay
these are ball wipes honestly this is
the least you can do guys
this is the literally you can carry
those in your pocket just refresh
clean your balls with this yeah you wipe
your fingers off after
after hot wings honestly
why not just go right down to the
bottles do them too thank you
i i don't think you guys are not
flexible enough to smell your own balls
i get it but i'm telling you
they're putrid they're swampy
they're chowdery it's it's dank
these wipes solved this ad is about
building confidence
the bundle also comes with a crop
preserver ball deodorant which we have
look at this ball deodorant
oh yeah that out i love look there's
even instructions it's the first one
take a shower
great men don't know then towel off it
tells you to dry off every instruction a
man needs is on this bottle
no excuses you have absolutely no excuse
anymore because a lot of guys look well
i don't want to use that it's a girly
product it's so this that you have no
excuse anymore
i mean what else other than putting a
map to your own bathroom on there
they've helped you out completely
there's no excuses anymore manscaped you
guys are nailing it
thank you manscape yeah you could twenty
percent have rescued my chin
look at this this is a little newspaper
they sent you so you can lay it down
and all your little hairs get caught on
it so you don't have to sweep your floor
up oh nice
i just i'm telling you that balls look
like elephant ears i mean why do they
look like amanda
you guys got to put lotion on them you
got to take care of them you got to
protect them
how many is this you don't even read the
news you just groom over top of it
you just shave your pubes off over the
news love
20 off with free shipping at
manscape.com use code
whitney that's 20 off with free shipping
at manscape.com and use code whitney
thanks manscape for making
our winter wieners look so good
did you entertain go back to new york no
no i'm when you leave new york you're
done yeah really joan didion the whole
thing
oh goodbye to all that when you're done
you're done you're done you're done when
you're done you're done so true
when you're done with new york you're
done and i know it because i go back and
i go never
can't do it the way i used to never
again doesn't i can't go to the grocery
store every day
yeah it's also like i've always
considered myself a person who like i'm
a new yorker i love new york but i also
there's if it is a strain of new yorker
a snooze stream no we stop seeing new
streams there's a strain of new yorker
that's
very annoying in their their world seems
very small you know giannis papas who i
love very funny comedian
but he was in la and i was like i drove
him from like palm springs up to the
mountains and he's like i can't believe
like it gets so much colder up here and
i'm like oh you're an idiot
like people from new york like are
morons some of them they like don't
understand anything
that goes on outside and your shots can
hardly drive yeah when andrew comes out
here he can't like figure out how to
function
new york man here's what i will say a
small bubble it's the greatest city in
the world but it's like
guys enough i just a more someone that
is my mother is from texas i have a
place called sherman texas near fort
worth i've spent a lot of time in texas
yes uh and i've spent a lot of time with
you and right
i understand that as someone that grew
up in europe you're gonna it's gonna be
a
sobering experience you work i'm gonna
be in l.a i'm gonna travel
i know but you and austin is it's you're
gonna be hot you're gonna be sunburned
you're gonna be grumpy you're gonna be
i'm gonna be that here annoyed it'll be
miserable here okay i'm gonna be
miserable wherever i live i mean
that's part of the deal wherever i go
miserable
i'm just gonna save money and like
listen i'm gonna be able to get on a
plane
go to new york get on the plane go to
l.a okay get on a plane hopefully go to
london wherever i want to go but you
know that austin it's still in texas
yeah you are aware of that you know that
i mean as a man who
will only eat with like gilded forks and
he i mean
you know you'll be eating out of food
trucks uh in austin
the rich the re the rich are there baby
that's dallas
you should be go i think you have a
point you should be in downtown i will
say
you're going to austin you're going 40
minutes out of austin by a lake
you're going to a place that is like uh
tries to be poor on purpose because it's
happening but i'm not going to go near
austin i'm going to be in the
i'm in the woods i'm in the woods okay
i'm like get on this doesn't feel
mentally healthy you're alone in the
woods it's not a good
thing you alone with your own thoughts
i'm not saying the fbi won't be keeping
tabs i don't think this is good i don't
know i don't like this
you do need to be around people when
you're left your own devices with
someone that you pay
enabling you i think i'm worried i will
be
should i pay 10 to enable that's that's
the problem i don't pay 25 people to
enable me
um i think it's a great move i think
it's going to be the move for comedy i
think i agree
yeah impress me i really believe i will
be there i really believe if joe's
opening that if rogan's opening that
club i will be there i'll have a place
there but
it's just like uh are you thinking about
doing this like
since we all don't have to live where we
think we had to live before are you is
this like permanent or are you like i'm
going to do this for
six months hey man i don't know what in
life is permanent never say so i don't
know if
in in three to five years maybe i'm like
i don't want to do a podcast
yeah i don't know but i want to make
enough and save enough money yeah to and
i can't do it in this state
they want all your money here yeah and i
i don't know what i don't know
it's kind of shitty the the that's the
reason but it's like
he really is but when you're renting
you're not you know what i'm saying for
six months you're not buying you're
renting
yeah i'm renting for six months then
looking around austin and then just
settling down mm-hmm
and then i want my base to be in a state
where i'm not being robbed yeah then i
can go all over the country and do
whatever i want
i mean it is i mean get listen if you
were paying these kind of taxes
but you were like you know california's
an ideal like paradise there's no
homeless
everybody's happy it's great yeah yeah
i'm getting i'm getting really
hit over the head but you know what
things are working out they can't get a
vaccine to people
people are waiting outside the forum
like they're waiting for billy eilish
concerts to get a syringe
this is an embarrassment it's become
kind of an embarrassment
is california just too big to be
governed it's too big to be governed
it's a country
what happened avenue is just out of
touch he's an effete wine merchant
who's out of touch this guy owns
vineyards am i a conspiracy theorist
that i think a lot of the decisions he
makes
is just despite his ex kimberly
guilfoyle yeah i feel like they're all
a fire kinky fight it's a weird he just
keeps getting more progressive just to
like piss her off like i feel like we're
here
i feel like wore the roses and we're in
between this like
toxic relationship at the end of the day
it's like i just want to go somewhere
where i can just start to think about
retirement i'm 36
it's time to start thinking about
wrapping it up
it's just such a hard thing to wrap my
head around that like this business is
over i know isn't it wild but i think
it's better to wrap your head around
that than your car around a tree
like many of the people that in that
stay in this town
are just they're going to be crazy can
we talk about the um my mental
deterioration over the past it's been
frightening
it's a little alarming it's been wild to
watch for a lot of us
it's you know comedians like we are
designed to get up and perform
us not performing for nine months like
nine months ago we were like there's
gonna be a couple months
i feel like um we're in the new normal i
feel like this has like
changed my brain yes well
you know i think that you're just it's
you're going through
a real you're a lot of things are you're
processing a lot of things
you're like oh the life i thought was
here is not here yeah
uh and it's not anywhere it's not in
austin it's nowhere yeah the life
before this is it's gonna be like 911
where it's like every time you got on a
plane afterwards you're like oh
yeah after this everything kind of
changes nothing's going to go that back
to like
i think things will go back to normal
eventually but they're still going to be
you're still going to be sitting
somewhere and somebody's going uh and
you're going to go
like it's going to be it's like travel's
going to be different going around the
world is going to be different
touring is going to be different
productions are going to be different
comedy's going to be different here's
what i'll say about the comedy stuff
though like i'm booking outdoor tours
like
like here's my problem comedians are
we're i think we're kind of standing in
our own way a little bit in terms of
of shows because we want everything to
be the way that it what like we're yeah
comedians will complain about fucking
anything you know
so it's like these outdoor shows are
totally working it's totally doable
why aren't in the spring and summer yeah
but i'm just but
we didn't we did san francisco in uh
november
outside there were heating lamps it was
fine like okay i think maybe it's
because
uh uh i came up in la and in l.a
you do bowling alleys i was doing like
chipotles and fucking
we used to do stand-up shows at jumbo's
clown room which was like a strip club
with
dwarves and shit like i'm used to doing
shows and
shitty outdoor crazy mess yeah i like
you new york club comics you're like i
need a club i need it to be inside i
need the ceilings to be low like
why can't well that's the best way that
but that's the highest form of
the art of stand-up comedy is a is a
small club right
um yeah i mean sure we'll do outdoor
shows if you have to but nobody wants to
do that yeah but what are we going to do
just live outside
you know what i mean like if we can't do
indoor comedy what can we do instead
like but why
can't we adapt why can't we adapt why
are we so bratty
because why because we're such babies
well it's not that we have to do it the
way we always did
it it's not even that it's just that
like most outdoor things
are not brand new they're not ideal look
here's the thing though when i went and
did the uh uh outdoor shows with cars
it was very weird for the first like
five minutes it was like they're honking
i was ju i was like this is awful i hate
it i don't wanna
five minutes in i was fucking like i get
it okay i know but we have evolved it's
called podcasting i don't want to
perform for cars i can just be funny for
an hour or two hours a week well your
fan base doesn't happen
uh so i'm sorry my fan base isn't my
other celebrity friends
i apologize you know i apologize
jennifer aniston and sandra who are
these people it's over
it's over ladies and gentlemen is tick
tock real yeah
benton makes a very good point people
have eight million
followers on tick tock the same person
will have like a hundred thousand on
instagram what's happening because
everybody on instagram
is an old witch like your friends and on
tick tock
everybody's just hot as fuck and we
don't care
and we don't care about old people and
what they're about like we're about
positivity and light and and showing and
being healthy and showing our unshown
our
our dicks that's what we're about so i'm
not
i'm not upset at old-school people what
is the most important platform right now
according to you i don't mind that
what is the most important platform
right now i'm on clubhouse all the time
okay we're talking with other venture
capitalist people in the business
do you all know about clubhouse
clubhouse is where it's at uh
that's where i am and people call i do
an investment
advice every night on there i did
investment advice last night really i
give out investment advice
well people interesting correct um i
uh is that the future for me as an
investor yes
i think so is clubhouse gonna replace
that's the investment advice right now
i'll give it to you for free uh
should i invest in uh
uh uh the rowing machine um
hydro it's peloton but it's a rowing
machine whatever you do
you have to remember that kindness heart
kindness is strength
i'm sorry kindness is strength i'm not
following
speed do you understand yep nope well i
guess i can i can't i can lead a horse
to water
so what i'm just saying is like i give
advice
that you need to know a little bit about
the market even get
i don't know i am like honestly i like
to be really
uh transparent with i do not understand
how the stock market works
i think you want to invest your money
that's what i've that's what i tell
people to do that's kind of the linchpin
of my advice
is the clubhouse gonna start being
moderated that's the big thing
but who like i mean is somebody gonna
come in and say because it's gonna go
full cue
any minute now no it's not you don't
think i don't think so
can you explain to me uh uh q and on for
our fans
since it's four months late i love this
this is when you know you're on like an
elderly person's podcast they're like
can you explain to me q9 and have trump
how did trump get elected no i want to
because i don't like to talk about
politics i like to talk about things
like that shit here's what i'm saying i
like to talk about things after the dust
has settled because i don't like to be
in the rigmarole
why be riding the wave i don't watch i
don't want to be in the drama i don't
like being relevant
agreed i don't like being relevant i
like going if that's all done you guys
can scuffle and
i'm going to talk about this later but
can i tell you something yeah that's
what comics used to do
really comics used to have the final say
shit would happen
news would happen someone would shoot a
special and they go this is what
happened this year and i have the final
say
people that's what they would do with
their standards you should
what are we doing like now now it's in
the moment there was no internet now if
you don't have the take
while it's happening yeah it's kind of
over yeah comedians used to
have some time to digest it write some
jokes about it
put out a special and go this is my case
they can still do that but i think it's
more important
now than ever to be like funny all the
time yeah all the time relentlessly
if you're hot on instagram you got to be
hot all the time
if you're smart you got to be smart all
the time if you're funny you're going to
be funny all the time
why if not the audience and people who
is used to what you're doing goes
they go somewhere else it's interesting
because it's just such a like skill
nobody's waiting on anyone special
even the biggest comedians in the world
nobody's waiting on your special
nobody's got their feet up and going
when's that special coming out nobody
cares anymore
if it's out and it's great then people
love it and they'll share it
but nobody's waiting nobody's waiting on
season four
ozark no one cares i'd never need to see
and i liked
the show but i never need to see another
episode again i'm over it
i'm done netflix can't do this where
it's like three months three years later
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah our attention
span is too short we're all too spoiled
now
we're all too spoiled we all want it now
now now and uh
uh we're all just like addicts i mean
but but where does this go i mean you
know i'm the super saturated love story
um because i'm an old uh fossil that's
still making uh
adapting books to be television shows
like this is a uh
a book that takes place in 2050
like what where do we go from everyone's
gonna have their own channel
soon well yeah everyone's gonna have
their own
platform their own channel the people
that are in interesting or crazy enough
or
funny enough or good-looking enough are
going to get attention
it's kind of like what it was it's just
the same thing it was
right what's interesting to people
hasn't changed what's attractive to
people hasn't changed what's funny to
people really hasn't changed
people's tastes are kind of similar it's
the way that they get it
people eat the same food they ate 50
years ago they just get it very
different ways
what are you getting on postmates what
are they bringing over steak and
potatoes
are we gonna start doing postmates
comedy no door-to-door comedy this is
what my
my grandfather rate so it's just a new
mechanism to get the same thing
that's what i'm trying to get all you
you people to understand you know is
there something to be said
i'm just devil's advocate here for a
little mystery
a little enigmatic you don't need to see
me all the time
see me some of the time it's just like
too much access
but maybe it's because i'm a woman and
women are grading yes
yeah i'm just saying like that's just
the norma desmond thing which goes it's
the pictures that have gotten
small i'm just saying you i think you
guys
can talk for 10 hours a week and people
love you i think if i talk for 10 hours
a week
i'm like get death threats i think it's
a different business model
maybe tell me i'm wrong maybe i'm this
is internalized sexism maybe i'm playing
the victim but i
i do not think the same business model
works for a female comic female comics
are the most loathed people on the
i'm like the most loathed person yeah
but why are they wrong
that's the question right because like i
understand what you're saying
but there's got what is that by the way
what bar
what oh this is a rice krispies this is
from a month ago you're not eating that
do you want a bar
no i didn't know what it was it was like
a beautiful lunch i don't look like a
rice krispie treat yeah you're not
eating there was no cake
anyway i know that he doesn't make cakes
i asked him i know
and no one does in l.a i guess the point
is no one eats i think people would love
to hear you talk i think that it has
nothing to do with gender and i think
it's just about betting on yourself
mm-hmm i mean people what is the root
for a female comic right now do you
think
this is a very interesting question it's
a great question you're probably right
that it is different for men and women
it is just different i mean it's like
look
dax shepard and i talk about very
similar people want to hear a guy be
vulnerable i mean
i just i think maybe i'm wrong but
is there a cap on how popular a woman
can get
with just talking oprah sally dressed in
an hour
sally jesse rashford visual that was uh
doing our visual on yeah but that was
also that was also a different
time when there were three channels you
didn't have any choices i agreed but i
mean there are
radio is there any woman who
has spoken 10 hours a week
that we're like can't wait to listen i
think prairie home companion i think
howard stern
i think you know kimball and corolla
were doing that radio show
yeah it's listen women get to go like be
the ones that laugh at the jokes the
robin on the house you're not wrong but
i think that there's
successful podcasters there are people
that are that are women and then um
you know radio is kind of a dead medium
i'm just curious
how long this podcast uh boom is gonna
go
it's on the edge of over okay the good
ones will stay around
yeah the ones that are funny the ones
that evolve the ones that are
uh people just it is pl it is really
obvious to people
who's doing this because they're bored
who's doing it because
who's doing it because they just have
like weird fomo or just who's doing it
because an agent or manager called you
and went you got to do something
and it's very obvious to people if your
heart and soul is in it and you love to
do it
uh people know that it's people can pick
that up
people can also pick up anything that
you do where you're
you know whether you're inauthentic or
you're just kind of like hey i'm just
going through the motions
there's a lot of people that are like i
have a podcast now because i guess i
gotta have a butt
it's like if you're into it you do it
you love doing it you build that
relationship with your fans
which is the best podcast fandom is the
best relationship ever
yeah it really is they love you it's
they're like your family they talk to
you they
update you on things that are going on
in their life some of them are scary and
yes they'll kill you
but at the end of the day it's it's so
much better
than having people that maybe they're on
a couch or they're in a break room
and they turn on a tv and you're there
and they're like okay
and you're playing some character and
they're like oh yeah you're funny as
that character
and they don't care anything about it
yeah you're lying to me you're
pretending what are we doing
right check us out people are i just
think but i do think that podcast for
podcast sake is on its way out well a
lot of people are just doing it as
they're like plan b
it's like when i was in mortgages i was
sitting at a diner and i gave the
waiter my card i said i'm in mortgages
and they just took out a car and he said
i'm also in mortgage
and he's a guy who's giving me a pizza
bagel so i said oh everyone in the world
is doing this
it's six months from over and i was
right i think this is six months from
who cares
not every show mind you but i mean so a
lot of the novelty
and a lot of the famous people who just
like did podcasts because they couldn't
go away
and are not doing numbers it's it's
actually because i need to like compare
things in order to understand it's like
similar to when in television uh back
when we did television
the sweeps week you'd try to uh cast
like a very famous person like a stunt
cast
and it wouldn't get the numbers right
that's not what people are they're
tuning in for the original cast not the
celebrity
right like it just it didn't it never
worked right you know it's like for a
minute uh
movies and tv shows were trying to cast
like infl youtube influencers to be on
tv shows thinking the audience would
follow them they're like no we're not
following you there
but there's something interesting about
when celebrities go on try to do a
podcast and no one gives a shit it's
like that's right you didn't sign up to
hear you talk for
three hours you haven't proven to us
that that's your skill right we want you
to sit there and look pretty or be funny
or do whatever you're doing
yeah and people don't follow them so
they're a lot of celebrities that start
podcasting they're not doing well well
it's also when they're allowed to go and
do other things they're going to do them
right so if you're allowed to make a
movie
or a tv show or you're allowed to go do
stand-up or you're allowed to go do or
if you're allowed to go on a vacation
yeah whenever you're allowed to do the
things you wanted to do
you're a lot of people are going to go
fuck this i'm not doing this podcast
i have a job yeah people just want to
feel like they have a job so a lot of
these actors and actresses are like well
i don't have a job right now i got to do
something yeah
and their agent manager is like hey man
you got to stay relevant but and a lot
of them are
starting podcasts and deciding to turn
them into like political preach sessions
also yeah
it's like what are you doing because
that's how to be relevant huh that's how
to be relevant
the politics is overtaken in hollywood
the stars of politics candace owens and
ben shapiro are much more famous
than hollywood nice you're about owens
yes is she
a performance artist like anyone anyone
in media at her level
is yeah and she certainly is yeah um
she's smart like she is she like i
always feel like play
like when people get like annoyed about
herniated culture i'm like don't buy
into this this is all just
i mean you know what it is it's like she
is
um capitalizing
on what you have to do
you don't have a choice the william f
buckley or whatever
intellectual conservatism you want to
imagine
doesn't work uh who he who shrieks the
loudest
is gonna get the attention so you gotta
say wild shit
all the time to even get the plane off
the ground yeah that's
so true and that's what these people are
all doing so it's like is she
uh whatever an artist performance artist
yeah is she any more of one than aoc
no that's what they all have to do art
our our politicians now are governing
off twitter
they want to be get retweets they want
to go viral i mean this is absurd
this is sick but this is where we're at
anybody that levels
that charge at her like oh it's a
grifter she's there she's that it's like
she's
existing in the in the climate that we
have right it's what it is
i hate a racket i hate you know me i'm
like
like i'll return something that was
seven dollars
are you calling um student loan debts
rackets yes okay
this clarification i don't like
listeners i don't like getting
bamboozled
are we allowed to say that word bamboo
someone look it up uh am i cancelled i'm
just saying i don't like a racket
and student loans are terrible terrible
i mean there's no i mean
there's no rhyme or reason to them at 19
years old
how am i i did think i needed thirty
thousand dollars yeah
but at 19 for ramen noodles at
they got they i just think this is they
got you hook line and sinker you're 19
years old
you're like yeah i'm going to be able to
pay that off cardi b look how rich she
got by
you think you're going to be able to
afford it because you're going to have a
degree and you're like i'll have a
degree so i'll get a job i have a job
i'll have money if i have money and put
these student loan debts off here's a
surprise you have none of that
truly fun fact and all the jobs that i
trained for no longer exist
now i have all these student loans and
i'm paying off this college
that taught me stuff that i can't even
use yeah exactly because
it's obsolete because i didn't go to
school to be a doctor a lawyer or a
teacher
so everything else is pointless what am
i a historian
this is old student loans it's a it's a
house there's no money in that
it's a hot topic bernie sanders is
talking about hot topic and we're
talking about
earnest ernest yeah we should mention
them mm-hmm
ernest ernest is um they offer low-rate
student loan refinancing
so basically they make it really easy
and flexible if you're drowning off
ernest
will rescue you this is an amazing
company with earnest you get
radically flexible payments and you can
pick your loan term by refinancing you
can reduce
your loan terms you can also combine
multiple loans which is really awesome
because student loans if you ever notice
if you go pay them off they're broken up
into like 15 separate loans oh my god
they make it so complicated they do
ernest is offering our listeners a
hundred dollar cash bonus refinance your
student debt at earnest.com
whitney terms and conditions apply now
ernest is giving our listeners a hundred
dollar bonus refinance your student
loans at earnest.com
whitney terms and conditions apply once
again you get a hundred dollar cash
bonus when you visit earnest.com
whitney to refinance your student loans
not available in all states terms and
conditions apply
visit earnest.com whitney for more
details terms and conditions apply
earnest student loan refinancing made by
earnest operations
llc nmls number
two zero four nine one seven california
finance
law license number six zero five four
seven eight eight
three oh three second street suite 401
north san francisco california 94107
venice visited earnest.com
license for a full list of licenses you
did go to college
benton valentine's day is coming up what
are you getting me
are you my valentine well according to
this ad an erection
i mean it's a weird time to bring this
question up don't you think
i just uh we're talking about roman well
we're talking about roman we're talking
about
hard dicks yeah valentine's day is
coming up and that's what i would like
a hard dick in a box okay
right how hard is it do it i could
probably uh yeah we could probably give
me that happen
valentine's day is coming up for a lot
of guys it's pressure
i know you got to get the you got to get
it up
you got to deliver first of all you have
to remember the date yes
very difficult right right you have to
get a gift yes guys can you remember
super bowl dates but valentine's day you
have to go into a flashlight
remember what the how many um
how many how many bases mickey robinson
made
in the 20s yeah but they can't remember
february 14th every year same you can
remember the amount of rings another man
wears but you can't buy one for
valentine's day
very confusing but it's valentine's day
stressful i'm the first person to say
it is a totally socially constructed
capitalist conspiracy shit show
everybody
you can never win on valentine's day
it's just too much pressure it's like
new year's eve it's just like it's never
going to live up to the hype
you're going to get flowers oh you got
me flowers that's so unoriginal
chocolate oh that's so unoriginal
it's just like i just feel like guys
can't win on this day
until now until now you know how you can
win
a hard dick that works
valentine's day is for you guys it's for
you boys and with
roman you don't have to worry about
dealing with ed because roman's got you
covered
you can get a free online evaluation and
ongoing care for erectile dysfunction on
the comfort and privacy of your home
which is the only place honestly i would
want to talk about ed because here's
what i'll say
having had experience with this it like
it's so complicated because
when a guy feels pressure to perform the
girl starts to get insecure you think
it's your fault
you start getting upset and crying and
i'm like sitting there in lingerie that
i got off amazon
that's probably already giving me
tetanus like i'm already upset you know
it's just
i love the idea of pressure to perform
like you're putting on a broadway player
we don't like we don't talk about like
men the
uh unrealistic expectations we have for
men in the bedroom we only talk about
women men have pressure too yeah
it's not fair it's not fair and
uh if i'm not hot enough for you buy
this product
i'm talking directly to my lover hard
penises are for everyone
here for a limited time get up to 35 off
your first month of ed treatment
order by 210 for guaranteed delivery by
valentine's day just go to
getroman.com whitney to get started
that's get roman.com
whitney um i don't know if i'm moving to
austin i want to get back to our fight
be a venture capitalist
because i do feel like we are the ross
and rachel of the pandemic
what a reference we are the scully i can
do this all day
i know and i love those shows you don't
understand that i appreciate that era of
hollywood i love it
i watched all of those shows and i
watched friends frasier
seinfeld just shoot me i watched melrose
place i watched nypd bloom no i still
have this thing in my heart
right like there's i just and maybe it's
because it's like i'm sad and i dude i
love the hemi i used to watch the
enemies i used
i love the um family like walking onto a
set you have an instant family that's so
pathetic i used to watch
snl every i used to watch letterman's
monologue every night i
loved all of that shit i used to i grew
up watching the dina carvey show and
then like
i watched it all and i just right now
it's it's very different
but i loved it i'm doing a red carpet
tomorrow on zoom
i mean it's just there's a certain point
we got it we got to say hey
let's buy ranch in austin texas i mean
that's the whole thing it's like who are
you even interviewing on this red carpet
on zoom
but you know texas is very dusty
it's there's i don't know how you keep
trying to find
the la's i i la is a litter box
texas is dusty i mean la's literally i
just
you are one of the most uh delicate
people i know
delicate people i know you uh well i
appreciate the finer things in life
texas is i'm just saying you're gonna
well there are planes trains there's
automobiles and if i don't like
something i can go and do that thing and
then go back
i'm going to live in a place where i
have greenery i have a nice big pool
okay it's going to be beautiful i'm
going to have a podcast studio i'm going
to have
a green screen to do videos and a
production capability
rogue is going to have a club yes i mean
why not when is that going to open
i don't know because uh before these
before probably before the comedy store
in the improv yeah
something that really bothers me about
you is you've always pretty much been
right
about this stuff so what's going to
happen this year are we touring the fall
in clubs in clubs i don't know if
theaters come back
but maybe i think hopefully clubs at
half to 75 capacity
um you know we have a mixture of heart
immunity depends on what happens with
these strains and if we get better with
treatments and mitigation and things
like i think
i was a person where i was going
this is all going to go back to normal
mm-hmm i'm now becoming person that is
starting to believe
no you've broken you're fully broken
yeah no i'm strong
i'm starting to believe that to be a
survivor
you have to accept the world's never
going back to what it was right never
you started wearing beanies i mean you
look like uh you know
[Laughter]
you look like a rogue homeless person
i'm here to tell you
the world's never going back to the way
it was you have to adapt and evolve and
survive
and so many people are going to fight
that tooth and nail because they all the
time they do
and they become dinosaurs and they go
extinct and that's what it is it's going
to be dude people go to miami people go
to austin
new york la dude it's been done yeah
who cares i mean truly who cares
no one can even defend you're the only
ones even tried everyone else i called
was like yeah good i'm leaving too i
mean
you're the only one you come from the
golden age golden era uh bill burr
saying
great uh sebastian's probably staying
yeah but guys that make 25 million
dollars a year don't have any advice
from it yeah yeah yeah
yeah that's the reality if you want to
make money
and you're like desperate you talk to
the person who has a job
not the guy that owns like five
companies right right right because his
advice is gonna be like
uh like when i first came to l.a i'm
like trying to lose weight rogue's like
go to chef ma'am
get a trainer build a gym you know and
it's like oh i
yeah you got to talk to the person who
lost 20 pounds
and they go oh well how about eating
like three times or whatever it is
so bill burr is a genius sebastian's a
genius they're the greatest ever
and of course they'll stay and they
should people like me
at the stage of my career i'm at i'm
like there's no downside
to getting out of here and seeing what's
up yeah you know i agree
yeah i mean those guys will i'm just
self i'm gonna miss you you're my only
i know but you'll i'll be back left i'll
be back
i'll be back a lot and you'll be in
austin people are going to live in a
bunch of different places
that's what's going to come out of this
i just people are going to be transient
suburbs are back transients is back
people that are like i don't want to
commit myself to any one area
ever question why are your fans so hot
every hot a lot of them are attractive
every like hot
guy i know loves you what is that
because they want to be like male
models i secretly want to be overweight
with the skin condition
like what is that every like weird like
random hot guy that i like dated on raya
will be due to love tim dillon i'm like
what is this
yeah i don't know um i don't know i
don't know i'm thankful for any and all
fans that i have definitely getting
worried uh about your ascent
well and that's been obvious to a lot of
people um
but it's all respect the silent film
stars
we all respect the golden age we all
respect
you know what i mean no we get it we
understand it you know
have you seen sunset boulevard i have
yeah you know it's like you wander into
a set and you're like i don't know why
i'm frightened
i know my way around here you know
everyone's like mrs cummings
you have to understand this is cummings
it's quarantine you must leave the
studio
you have to understand that if someone
like tooth and nail
clawed my way to figure out this
business and i i finally know how to do
it yeah
and everyone's like now go do this
business that you don't understand at
all
you succeeded and then everyone in the
comments is saying you're a cunt
on youtube but keep doing it i'm like i
kind of preferred when the lawyers
told me i couldn't make that joke people
are gonna say you know what i'm saying
yeah it's like it's like you guys are
like it fucking sucks to do sitcoms
lawyers are telling you you can't make
jokes i'm like yeah well i just did
rogan's podcast and now i'm getting
death threats
yeah so sitcoms actually i'd rather
fight with lawyers
well i just i think you've you've
succeeded so much
that you can kind of take a chill pill
you've done it yeah but you know we
can't do that well i know i'm not saying
i'm not saying but like you you've
succeeded
in ways that were unimaginable to the
young girl that moved to l.a
right maybe i i mean unimaginable
success you've had
so at a certain point you got to go i
did it not successful enough to get tim
dillon to show up on time for his
podcast
clearly don't have that kind of success
yeah
it was scheduling but sunday 10 a.m
couldn't make it work i think at a
certain point you just have to say like
do what you enjoy
that's the ticket that's the ticket
don't worry
about what other people say don't worry
about comments don't worry about any of
that what do you
really enjoy do that yeah that's the
ticket
you've earned the right to do that
you've won
so now winning means do what you want
hmm that's the move
that's it what's going to happen you're
going to go to austin yeah you're going
to go nuts
you're going to hate it you're going to
come crawling back and come live with me
i don't three months i give them till
that sounds like a nightmare i'd rather
be covered in black widows
in the middle of a ditch in texas than
come crawling back to los
angeles with you and have you like
you're like i'm hosting an emmy after
party on zoom
lisa coudreau is going to be there
you must put on powder get your get your
instagram
story ready what she's at the top of the
stairs you know
she's gonna shoot me like at the end of
sunset boulevard she's just gonna
shoot me with a gun and then her dogs
are gonna eat her
and then we're all gonna have to be like
man no one saw that coming
except anyone with eyes
i mean i do i i definitely think uh the
hair needs to go back
hot whitney at least because i don't
i definitely as soon as the hair started
up my brain
that's what my brain is probably not
natural to have to die by the brain by
the
i mean see seeping and how many things
have you done you've done pink you've
done green
i've done pink i did blue and now this
is blue and purple
yes comedians are meant to be doing
stand up every night i agree i agree
with you
i feel like if i may i feel like for the
first six months i really held
tight i held steady i was steady i
forgot what you look like
around thanksgiving is when i started do
we have a photo of her before the hair
i like to forget what she looked like
before the hair i started to break
around thanksgiving that's when i really
really started to catch up to me the
demons started to catch up to me
and not doing stand-up the addiction
that was keeping all the voices at bay
uh started catching up to me it fucks us
all i get it we're all losing our minds
um
and uh uh that's me with brown hair
um i i think i gotta go back to brown
hair i think
yeah gotta pull it together it's gone
too far but this is
this is my argument against podcasting
it's
people this has been enabled people love
it love it love it whereas in tv they go
no no you can't do that you look insane
there's different mediums different
strokes
for different folks because i feel like
you can get you can go down a wormhole
on social media where you can find
anyone to encourage bad choices
that's absolutely true but you got it
you got it something to be said for the
old school publicist who's like yeah we
don't let her speak
like there's yeah i agree because i was
like fire everywhere
i'm going rogue yeah and then i was like
oh there's a reason publicist
right this ridiculous uh
um byzantine system works because
talent we're not we we're mentally ill
we shouldn't be talking we shouldn't be
making our own choices we shouldn't be
able to record ourselves in blast at any
time when you were on the honeymooners
you were one of the most iconic figures
in television
okay you worked with jackie gleason you
worked with our carney
these were legends it's we are
i'm so grateful we're grateful to have
to have known you
and two of the gifts that you've given
to us the episode
were you and ethel ate the chocolates
when they were going down the thing
by the way it is it actually is uh
clorous leachman passed away
yes and uh i had like four pictures of
me and her to choose from
yeah i mean it's sad it was they said
the close legion died not that you took
pictures yeah
listen you have to join the ranks of the
legends you know what i wanted to do
to join the ranks ascend the golden
staircase i want to be a judge on one of
those masks shows
mass sing i want to just be a judge well
that's nice i want to do that
well isn't that do comedy most of the
year two months as a judge on one of
those ridiculous shows because people
still watch those but you can do it
they're fun
that i had i have fun doing that can't
you get that gig
yeah so i was the guest host on mass
dancer last night i went and shot it
like a couple months ago
um it was a fucking blast are you in the
studio and everything yeah okay yeah we
went and shot it was like ashley tisdale
and paul abdul and
uh brian austin green and dr ken i was
like who and who
robinson brian wants to green the guy
from nine into a now yes but he won matt
but this is
not a two of the first one but here's
what i'll say remember he shot his
friend
or his friend killed himself on 902-0
remember that i brought it up with a
mass dancer they cut it out
oh really i was like yeah i remember how
was brian green not shot himself
he's making that mass dancer money i'm
sure he is i want some of the best i
would
isn't that does not sound fun everyone
but here's what i'll say i like tv sound
good
i went you could see someone dress up
like a crab
on the fox slot i went on the mass
dancer i was like this is what hollywood
should be a ridiculous
spectacle with a bunch of idiots not
pretending they're better than anyone
we're in sequin costumes we're doing
dumb dances
with washed up slut this is what this is
what it should be
right ridiculous circus a ridiculous
clown show spectacle
yes silvio berlusconi 101. why were we
pretending we were artists and had a
craft and we were taking ourselves
we're fucking pigs we're disgusting
mentally ill pigs that
uh are entertaining for like an hour a
day this is what we should be doing
right well i wish you luck in your new
career
at the mass dancer i've never seen the
show but i'm sure it's good
and i think people need to watch it in
between
handfuls of oxycontin or whatever
they're doing in this country whatever
people are doing in this country
in between that while they're scratching
themselves in an opioid range
they should watch brian austin green
dress up like sebastian from the little
mermaid
and dance it's pretty fucking
entertaining
i bet it is i think that you know what
it is because that's what it's come to
is that
watching people dance in costumes you
realize like when you see an actor
acting you're like oh that's the guy
that dated the so-and-so or that's the
guy that you know
so and so like it's ever actors
distracting now because we know too much
about them
right you know what i'm saying but
someone in a costume performing in sync
you're just like oh i can just sit here
and
that was the only time i've been
entertained in like months
well i gotta watch it because it is
super popular and i have friends that
watch it who i respect so i'm like why
are you watching that but they're like
what are we supposed to do
list your podcast over and over again
i'm like yes because it's like
mindless it's what entertainment's
supposed to be mindless fun
we can't play a clip from can't be silly
yeah we can play it
um mindless campy hold on whitney
cummings mass dancer
yeah because i'm interested it also
could be my dear friend kate upton
had a baby has a similar height oh i'm
sorry okay well kate up just my actual
friend
okay i'm calling peter no no no why not
i'm gonna see if she really knows who
you are tweet
if she doesn't answer this could be kate
upton
like i you know it was like i don't
that's a weird trailer
that's you know whatever it's just like
silly shit you know what i mean it's
insanity
it's it's apocalyptic entertainment
you know mass dancer they're just
watching
[Music]
do you watch this ben do your wife watch
it here we go look at this
this is a here's a television bouquet of
new clues for you
it's a game show you have to figure it
out it's math
you have to be engaged tv knows it's tv
knows it's not relevant anymore they
know they have to do something to make
you addicted
it's a game i call rapid fire oh let's
see what
fire like you just will start look at
the editing
they know how short our attention span i
know it's probably i understand this is
this is perfect let's see what question
you asked
she graduated i don't know
what was that would you retire i've
never thought about it
that's because she's young how are you
at memorizing
dialogue i would say i'm a pro could be
an actor
okay what would be worse running out of
gas or
running low on battery on your phone on
my phone of course
yes so what does that mean mindless sir
i know what you're talking about
from the clues who do you think this is
ken i still think this is an actor
and a trained dancer i thought this was
heather morris i mean this is the future
of tv right
okay well count me out
i mean count me out that's all it's like
there's no interest i mean imagine
sitting on a panel and being like
hey who are you like it's a hell
what you were showing me is a hell to
drive my car to that lot to sit on that
studio
get covered tested swabs in your nose
and ass
you sit there and you're gonna sit next
to ashley tisdale and then you gotta go
oh my god so you acted you sang
what's your relationship like your
sister do you have a tick-tock with your
sister
to me that is the seventh ring of hell
truly well i get it people love it yeah
i mean
you will there's a point where network
television will come to you with an
amount of money and you're like
work four days for this amount of money
and you will change your mind
and when that happens everyone caves you
know what you're like the new patent
oswald he's like fuck network
you guys aren't the first people to say
fuck hollywood
like like in like um all
comics were doing this like 10 years ago
yeah and pat and oswalt was like so
succumbs are stupid and then he's on
he's in ratatouille and on two and a
half me or whatever
i'm in i'm trying to get into this way
house king of queens like what are we
doing you guys
you all sell out eventually i've been
around
long enough to know that you all sell
out eventually do you know what the sway
house is
i do no you don't yes i do what is it
i'm not a pedophile so i haven't been
there tim
everyone is over 18. but it is a sway
house it is it is a requirement to join
i believe
it is where they go they make tick-tock
content and they do their lazy
cheerleading
uh for the camera which is not
sustainable why would you talk about it
is there such an
anger because it's not sustainable it's
not so such an anchored health
we are wired for completion storytelling
will never go away
oh boy it will never go away who says
women are grating uh
when you talk about these tick tockers
it sounds like you've just swallowed a
bit of
acid no and i used to dance in the
mirror when i was 18.
i'm so glad i didn't put it on instagram
or like on something permanent well i'm
just saying don't hit on my boys
uh we're just trying to do what we got
to do you know we've taken over this
town
and that's that's where i'm at you know
that's interesting
the comics that have become somewhat
irrelevant during this time yes
is this uh theory carrie anyway like i
do feel like it's kind of like
survival of the kindest you know because
yeah the people that are kind to each
other are the ones that get on each
other's podcasts
i think because it's kind of become like
the people that were dicks
yeah are kind of going away yes that is
true but i also think they'll be back
huh they'll be back you think yeah but
i think that there's never gonna be one
world anymore
that's the thing that's hard to
understand and that's what there will
never be one world anymore yeah so the
people that are gone
are gonna come back but they're gonna be
in another dimension and they're gonna
do things like the masked answer that i
don't give a shit about
and everyone's gonna be like yeah but
there's a bazillion people watching i'm
gonna go yeah but i don't care yeah and
then they go oh yeah he's got a little
dumpster on youtube i'm like yeah but
there's half a million people watching
like really like but whatever we don't
care that's cool too
everyone's gonna live in a different
world i don't want to have to live in
somebody else's world i don't want them
to have to live in my world
choose your own reality 2021 you can
choose your own reality you're
like you can have but you can also do
this for two months and then go to your
other thing for
two months of yeah yes it's like a week
you shoot that for like a week get in
get the fuck out
ask dancer i mean it's just a great so
that's the argument to stay in l.a well
you're right
i'm not gonna go to austin hopefully
i'll get on the masked dancer and i'm
not even big enough to be a judge
i'm not nearly big enough to be a judge
that's what's crazy you will at some
point
you're saying funny because tim's like
fuck hollywood they won't hire me they
will you just keep calling them
pedophiles every week you call them
baby dick eating pedophiles like they
want to hire you they you and theo are
like full
the hollywood won't hire me they don't
respect me it's like all you do is say
that they
are uh hire us to do what run pizza
places with babies being trafficked
yeah well here's the deal you're not
you're making it very hard for them
we do business with you what we're doing
is relevant
and what you're doing is irrelevant
that's the reality
the mass dancer is not relevant to
anyone except corn fed
pigs who are like falling out of their
disgusting cars
and crawling into a golden corral that's
who watches that show
people whose brains have leaked out of
their ears and there's nothing wrong
with that they deserve entertainment too
by the way
even younger demo than tick tock i'm
getting 10 year olds on the mass dancer
oh and you should be proud
why why would i call hollywood
pedophiles when they're marching
why would i because i was on there and
they were like you know this is like a
kids show and i was like i had no i
think they could
if you cut this up eclipse you should
cut it up to make it look like me and
whitney got a big like a big fight where
i go
you're a rat well i don't think it's
relevant i'm telling you very smart none
of you will do this but
i'm telling you i get views what you
should do
is actually make it look very
like contentious and put like dun dun
dun
music it is it's not contentious like i
feel like we're still healing from our
fight
it's not contentious on my own and
you're focused
i don't even do this anymore like you're
talking to me as a comedian i'm not even
a community no you're fully like
in your business man hold the line i
want to talk to your brother i want to
have an hour conversation oh you should
about this really quick am i buying
bitcoin this week sure
why because it's it's going to you know
be a thing it's going to be here it's
going to stay
i i think that uh you know it'll go up
i don't think there's going to be a
massive crash i think it's something
that you should own you should
absolutely own one i took my money out
of cannabis
keep money in cannabis i keep money in
electric cars keep money in everything
that's going to happen
right cannabis is going to be legal
electric cars are the wave of the future
tesla's massive stock like you know but
right now the two most things that i
believe in most
are video game stores and movie theaters
that i believe in most in terms of the
trends that are happening
hollywood's dead but movie theaters will
work like no one's making movies but
movie theaters are
this episode should be called hold the
line do you guys title your episodes
hold the line i love that you hate
hollywood movies but you're investing in
movie theaters
but here's the thing what you're calling
hollywood
is actually just a f a fire
and hollywood is actually the things
that you hate
which is people like me the tick tockers
yeah
i don't disagree or read corvette what
about snapchat
no it's fine okay as the authority on
all things social media well i just i
think tick tock is a now i
don't have a lot of followers on tick
tock because i've devoted most of my
time to
managing money but i
i recognize the power of being young
hollywood and being 17 years old and
having people like you hate on me but
that's okay that's part of my journey
part of my journey to get hated on and
still flourish
my haters make me stronger that's all
there is something kind of amazing about
this new
uh generation they dm each other they
help each other it's such the opposite
of how comedians are it's a
collaborative generation it's
we're taking over we yeah oh
i am the demilios and they are me we're
all one but why did
why that i'm just curious what about
what they did
was they're just the girls next door and
they just dance they were consistent and
did it they just did it
you know what do you want me to do i
can't tell you why
me and my friends are the coolest people
in the country if charlie demilio went
on the show he's my best friend
charlotte emilia is my best friend if
charlie dimiely went on a
theater tour tomorrow how many tickets
would she sell in america
i don't know is it a mad question
i bet it would be a few i bet you can
pull some numbers
in the united states i bet these aren't
like random china numbers
let's say let's say a quarter let's say
three-quarters of her tic-tac-toe
is fake can you see that still leaves
her that's 25 million people
can you see on tick-tock where your
followers live
like you can on instagram i don't know i
don't think so
that's shady to me i'm sure it's shady
of course tick-tock shady yeah but you
got to get on triller
what's that triller's the new tick tock
what you old goat
triller's the new tick tock thriller
yeah it's a new tick tock did you
whatever happened with stitch snitch
twitch
twitch twitch is there we're going to
start a twitch empire people are making
money on twitter yeah
yeah what's happening with twitch people
gaming
should we do the only fans roast i want
to do a roast that's
on only fans and it's like like the
dirty jokes that we're not allowed to
tell i don't want to shit on sex workers
okay i'm not an old conservative
republican like you i'm a liberal
progressive
black lives matter aoc stan so i don't
want to
only fans yeah i don't want to shit on
people to try to make a living
i think we can i think if you want to do
an independently
distributed uh uh thing you could do an
only fans
you can shoot a special put on only fans
no i don't think so i think we need to
not i think we should stay off only
fence
okay let them have it okay people gotta
have something
you know what i mean yeah when are you
leaving me
march first i go on the road in a you
know
what happens to all the like we put so
much effort into your house here it goes
it goes on a truck and it drives 20
hours
not even too much in austin all the
furniture looks better in the texas
house
it's true absolutely it is so my
aesthetic it's beautiful
it works perfectly and and uh you're
gonna live together no he's gonna have a
house with his wife
okay yeah he can afford a house in texas
you know i'm jealous i'm jealous i feel
left out and
it's yeah you're gonna be fine we're all
gonna be back at la i'm gonna come back
to la all the time
it's nothing if i didn't tell you i was
moving to texas you wouldn't know
you know what i mean maybe oh that might
be true yeah yeah because you've been in
palm springs and you've been yeah yeah
i've been here i've been there and
it's just like i'm just telling you we
have to move all the time that's the
other thing about comics like it's like
we are here's the thing man
i guarantee you listen you don't want to
hear this because you're fixing up this
house it's going to be beautiful
i'm just saying there's a real
possibility you're not going to want to
spend time
where you quarantined that's so
interesting well
you know also the the house that i'm
staying in now where i had covered
the bedroom i had it in i can't even
look at it i just
like it is i don't want to think about
it i think when the quarantine ends
yeah you're going to look at this house
and you're going to go this reminds me
well this is going to be i have a water
yeah you're going to say well yeah but
it's not
it's going to be still the house that
you were in jail
and you're going to go i don't know and
you're going to put on the market you
sell it for a good amount of money
interesting and then you're gonna go
you're always gonna have a place here
you're gonna downsize a little bit
you're gonna get a beautiful place here
and you're gonna buy a place in austin
or texas or wherever for for
good reason and you're gonna buy a rate
you'll probably have a ranch places
without income tax are
nevada florida florida texas uh
tennessee alaska yeah maybe i don't know
i don't know all of them yeah
washington state maybe i don't know but
i'll tell you this i think you're going
to live here for a while if you leave
her for a year after the reno's done i
think you'll live here for a year but i
think eventually you're going to put it
on the market and go
and you're going to put it on the market
because this was the quarantine house
interesting yeah i believe so i feel
like we had a good quarantine here it
was great i don't think i haven't had a
negative like we kind of made it we
didn't have a negative experience but it
doesn't matter you got to keep moving
you're a shark
got to keep moving that's so true got to
keep moving you got to keep moving i
have to keep moving i went to go get the
house in malibu and then i went
this isn't enough this isn't foreign i
need a change i need everything
yes your cabinet everything to change i
need out of this state i need out of
this thing i can't be like
driving to west hollywood being like is
the comedy store open having another
dinner
looking at a all my friends don't live
here anymore
comedy's not coming back and i'm driving
around like looking at the bombed out
buildings being like well it's gonna but
one day it's gonna
nope gotta be new it's all gonna always
be new and i'm sure five years in austin
i'll be like
it's gotta be new yeah i'll keep a house
there for taxes but i'm like
i might go i'm getting an apartment in
new york city they could be like really
no you're gonna be like a palm beach
person ultimately
it's very like a very popular very yeah
very possible where you belong epstein's
house is for sale
it's beautiful home but it's not nearly
as nice as some of the other ones
but yeah man i i don't think i'll spend
the rest of my life in texas yeah
but i do think i'm there i think it's a
five-year game there
i'm 36 40 41 like i i don't know how
much
i don't know how much juice is left in
anything yeah
that's true and like i you know who
knows there's a podcast
in five years am i like god i love this
am i like this has become something else
is it a late night show that i host on
youtube and on other platforms
am i like i do i want it in five years
to have enough money
i want to make a movie i'm just gonna
move to la for a year and like try to
make a movie
and then ben comes out every month and
we spend a week having meetings i don't
know
it's all fine he'll travel i'll travel
he's the only dude i really need
in terms like a collaborative
partnership that we work on stuff all
the time
and you know he'll have a wife they'll
have a few kids but like
he works he shows up all the time and
works and like if i gotta travel or if
he's gotta go somewhere and we gotta
pitch something or whatever
we'll do it but i just think getting out
of this area
where literally everything i know is
just over yeah and for me to keep saying
like oh no
but you got to understand when it comes
back
i keep saying when it comes back i start
to feel like a crazy person
i really do start to feel like a crazy
person because it's like i don't know if
it's coming back
or how it's coming back you know they're
like no when it comes back it's like
it's like a girl who's you know you give
the relationship but they both go away
to different colleges
yeah like number one when we see each
other yeah
on thanksgiving are we kidding we have
christmas and it's just not it's
over and it's it by the way if i was in
new york during quarantine i would
fucking jet out of there
it's just wherever the hell you were
it's like whatever you were and
especially the scene in l.a has been
bombed do we know how chappelle got
covered i'd have no idea
some person was with him that i think
had it right right right yeah because
those shows
um were doing okay i mean i don't know
i'm touring next month we'll see
i'm touring next month too where are you
going tell everyone
i'm going to uh baltimore i'm going to
royersford pennsylvania
baltimore magooby's love it this is such
a great club i always run
my specials there before i shoot them i
do magus in baltimore with comedy
connection providence rhode island i'm
doing uh
royersford pennsylvania a dome a heated
dome i mean it's what we have to do now
uh how many is it half capacity yeah
whatever
something yeah looking at people in
hazmat suits hilarities in cleveland
uh zany's in chicago sold out or the
improv in chicago schaumburg improv sold
out okay well not sold out yet
amazing tickets left yeah i mean i'm
excited
i'm excited for the next chapter but
there's got to be a next chapter
and i think that for too long i was
still trying to reshuffle
the cards here and i was not it wasn't
exciting
wasn't exciting i guess what i'm
realizing about podcasting as i'm
talking to you is i'm kind of shy
yeah like i'm not this is like this is
hard for me to do right
it's difficult because you're like
hiding behind a computer writing the
thing
giving it and then doing the thing after
it's been practiced for a long time
well for the every time i leave a
podcast i have a complete nervous
breakdown i was like that was terrible
i'm quitting podcasting
for the no because you're when you're
authentic you're real everyone loves you
it's just like
the you listen everyone's got to get
used to it it's very different
and i think that like for the first half
of your career
the movies were silent these were silent
films so you just had to look at someone
and they knew what you were talking
about
you didn't have to learn dialogue or
anything and then when they started
doing color
they did color and you're like oh my god
i'm in color and then they did
then they did talking in the films
dialogue you've seen all of these
advancements happening
now people have tvs in their home like
you saw people get tvs in their home
in the beginning you were on a show
called the shadow which was a radio show
which was one of the top radio shows and
they would interrupt it every now and
then when there was an announcement
about the war
but you've gone through all of these
things
and now you're like now you just have to
learn how to be yourself now now you're
just back
oh god what we're doing now is back to
the basics i feel like i'm like
valerie i'm full valerie cherish from
the comeback at this point
yes yeah a little bit i mean wow
do you not watch tv at all you don't
watch shows no nothing
i watch succession i watch cobra kai
i used to watch ozark i watched curb
sometimes
not a ton but i got to be honest with
you not a lot of tv
interesting dude i really i'm more
listening to podcasts or i'm more and i
don't listen to a ton of podcasts
compared to other people i know people
listen you listen to podcasts as a fan
you like if i'm interested in something
i will listen to a lex friedman podcast
for an hour and try to learn about what
somebody's talking about
i feel like i should have a kid with lex
friedman
yeah that would be interesting what a
well-adjusted kid
don't you think that's a good idea i
feel like we should have a kid together
we don't have to date or anything no
yeah i mean he's an interesting guy he's
a sweetheart brilliant guy sure good
girlfriend you have my blessing
okay thank you you have my blessing so
you listen to lex's podcast i listen to
lex
i want to learn shit okay every now and
then not always
but i mean i don't know man i don't i'm
i'm i mean do we watch tv ben i don't
really think we do like
it's boring i'm bored yeah i'd rather
like go on clubhouse like listen to
people and talk shit like real people
yeah yeah yeah it's kind of like boring
well clubhouse is like the new reality
tv
yeah you know what i mean but with re
but reality tv's never been real this is
like the real reality tv
right it's a bunch of people they get
people getting fights people are like
it's interesting yeah i like it it's
just pure chaos
yeah just mutiny yeah yeah
i love you well i love you too and i
hope you come visit it i feel like we
did a very
mellow kind of serious podcast today
people need to hear the truth
hold the line hold the line
i love you i love you thank you for
having me thank you for watching thank
you for not canceling
um thank you for having me tim dillon's
show
tim j dillon on instagram twitter uh
i'm on clubhouse follow me on clubhouse
tim j dillon uh
you can't get on clubhouse without an
invite oh then don't not public yet
i'm a venture capitalist thank you
[Music]
[Applause]